I think the American dream is dead you
know I agree with Trump when he said
that and I think that's actually a
separate question because I think the
American dream is really more about what
people think about which is opportunity
and jobs and quality of life and I think
that's separate from family and like you
said Traditional Values patriotism
I think that you can't talk about these
Trends without talking about at the same
time the secularization of America
that's the biggest problem because
without religion without a genuine fear
of God
there's really I mean the word value
doesn't even have a moral connotation
people can pick and choose them but then
it's a matter of preference it's totally
subjective they're also then not binding
if you don't believe in God and
therefore a judgment and therefore
accountability then you can feel
whatever you want is right or wrong but
there's nothing that actually binds you
there's really no incentive to follow it